damien cepal bozza oui j'ai une
affection particulière pour stéphane
plaza il ya une agence de chez de lui à
100 mètres de chez moi alors ils
appellent la forêt sur quelle chaîne
oui même si la personne à côté de lui
non la balle à la main tu peux lui
demander ma voix côté quand je te vois
je vois que l'émission café toutes ces
émissions à la jeune fille valérie
brouillard c'est incroyable c'est là
qu'ont développés dans cette émission
non mais je pense qu'il regarde là bas
j'ai même pas commencé
[Applaudissements]
le prénom de tout le monde est tombé sur
le comment s'appelle la seule fille là
bas au bout de la table
kelly non c'est grâce à ça de ma mère
elle s'appelle comment qui dit non mais
ça plaît là au moins ça fait deux ans
qu'il fait l'émission attend l esma
chésa et bien sûr quasi c'est rachida
dati non rachetable date et on va
demander à france 3 de bien vouloir
venir la chercher
merci